more than a year local businesses have
really struggled to keep their doors
open due to the immense hardships of the
pandemic
many like sisters oriental market and
video on fremont and bruce
are still struggling today kate houston
spoke to the owner who was making a
last-ditch effort to stay in business
for 31 years these shelves have remained
stocked with traditional foods and
ingredients
but after a very difficult year the
owners are now fighting to stay open
seven days a week 365 days a year dalvon
lungwrath can be found preparing and
serving popular laotian dishes to her
loyal customers
papaya salad and a beef blob
like a louse thai style rarely ever
taking a break
mung wrath is the steady force behind
sister's oriental market in video
one of only a handful of lao asian
restaurants in las vegas
i'm so happy that's why i come up on
that 31 year
long long long time after being denied
pandemic financial assistance three
times
long wrath will have to close this
family run shop
31 year of my life here you know
my home my lines all my family my
friends come here you hang out
for her loyal customers this comes as
heartbreaking news
i've been to vegas and i think every
time that i do i come here
conte lee ditt flew in from minnesota
tuesday morning
her first stop the market luggage still
in hand
it's more like authentic love school
that
we search for like stuff that is
is like kind of like at home that we
love now lung roth is searching for a
way to stay open or for someone to take
over the business
special loan like a government loan or
something
it will be helpful help me a lot kate
houston
8 news now now if they can't secure a
loan or some sort of financial
assistance
the business does plan to close after 31
years
at the end of the summer brian that
would really be a shame